you're
i mean you've spoke you've been brave in
you know telling your story not some
dramatic thing but just telling the
things you've seen
did it encounter did it impact your
career
is that why more people haven't come out
like uh
you've mentioned uh roswell like how
what advice do you give to people to the
community to me as a scientist
for ways to go forward about this topic
and
still have a uh you know not being
put in a bin in society that he's a loon
or she's a loon or that person mine is
to get away from the little green men
just to
divorce the two little green men and you
know and i've talked to lou elizano
about this
you know and and the group that they're
working with which is incredible i mean
they've got steve justice who used to
run skunk works where they
built you know projects now louis
alexander as you mentioned was a program
director
he ran the a-tip program at the pentagon
and a-tip was a program that was tasked
with investigating
any kind of uh on ufo's uap
so what's funny is the unofficial
official report that i joke about yeah
the guy who wrote the unofficial
official report was actually an original
member of atip
and the original stuff that atip did was
foia exempt
and people how do you know that i go
because i stood there with the memo in
my hand that said these are
did literally i watched the dod memo
that said it and it was signed
so he was one so that's why the that's
why i caught the unofficial official
report it was never
it was never releasable because people
go oh i put in a foil request and i
didn't get that i go well just because
you put an afford request to get it i go
because
how much how much time do you think that
guy is going to spend to get you the
information that you requested if you
can't find it
i actually got called by the navy i had
a
commander in a navy call me about right
before the article came out in the new
york times it was this was starting to
come back
and she had called me because there's
been there was a foia request for stuff
about the nimitz incident and i said
do you know of anything she called me
she goes do you know of anything else
besides the
the situation reports that come off the
ship you know and you gotta remember
when the situation report comes off the
ship that's like third hand so we
tell someone they tell someone that
person has to write it up
so there's all kinds of inaccuracies in
it
but then there's the unofficial official
report that's actually pretty well
written there's some errors in it but it
was you know i didn't help write it i
just
did it and he did a really good job of
researching it and figuring out who's
who in the zoo and the players
um so she called me and said is there
anything out there and i said
officially out there she said yes i said
i don't know anything
i knew of the unofficial official report
which is that one
but i'm not you know if you don't know
about it i'm not going to tell you
because that's not my job
and nor did i care i mean did
in that whole situation you mentioned
lube i mean did you
think about your impact your career like
just to get back to the question did do
you think
others other pilots
other thing other people like in
roosevelt
are thinking about this kind of thing
why aren't they talking about this why
are people afraid
to talk about this well honestly the
military and the press there's a
distrust i'll just tell you that right
now
we typically don't like talking to the
press because if i talk to you
you know especially when i do even the
tv shows you know because i've been on a
couple shows
when you look at it you know they come
to my house and they film me for two
hours
yeah and then what you see on the screen
is five minutes
well and yeah and the other thing with
the press let me give you my perspective
from autonomous vehicles
is the clipping happens
yes but also the incompetence
let me just call out journals
they're not thinking i mean so so here's
the thing
i've i have a phd and i've taken
painfully too many classes from like
physics and math and i also have a deep
curiosity about the world
i read a lot that seems to be missing
with journalism so you're talking to a
person who's not going to
push the story forward in an interesting
way not the story but the
actual investigation of
perhaps one of the most amazing things
that humans have witnessed in history
like you it might have been nothing but
who knows
what you witnessed might have been from
a sort of debunking perspective might
have been some kind of trick of mind
if you and others have hallucinated
something
it could be some simple explanation
but possibly it was
uh something not of this world and
to not do justice to this story
from a scientific perspective it seems
at best negligence and so yeah that's
true for
journalists that's true for others we
it's just
it's human nature yeah if we if we can't
if we see something that we can't
explain
then sometimes if you just yeah maybe
it's just me and you let it go away
and you don't think about it you know
maybe it'll just you know it's
it's you ignore it um the other side is
the inquisitive mind that says well what
was that and i want to i want to dig
more into it
you know and if you you you look at it
or you're going against the norm
um you can get ostracized you know and
if you look at you know
einstein is the perfect example i mean
he started coming up with some of his
theories some of the top physicists in
the world were like
dude you're you're a nut job and he's
literally proving them
but he didn't have you know he proved
him in theory
but he didn't have the means to actually
do the experiment to prove
his theory there's a great book that i
recommend people read
called proving einstein right by jim
gates
that uh talks about like the hard work
that people try to do years after
to try to experimentally validate
the predictions that einstein made with
uh with his theories
it's fascinating but yes at the time
it's kind of crazy what he's saying
yeah if you look at it back at the time
don't we we look at it now and go well
the guy was a walking genius and he was
but if you go back in time when he was
doing it it was like what are you
talking about
you